let's talk about a guy that we need to
not hear each other
to discuss and that would be josh allen
the quarterback of the buffalo bills who
after a slow start last night turned it
around
and got it done for the buffalo bills it
was persistence it was not giving in to
this idea that maybe it's not there not
you know that's a sign of a great team
every once in a while you have a team
that's doing well and then they stumble
into a game where it's just not
going so easily and and and it just kind
of becomes a self-fulfilling
prophecy chris and the next thing you
know
you've lost the game the bills woke up
when they needed to
they found a way to pull away from the
steelers and yes the steelers their
credit tried to make it interesting but
it just became clear the longer that
game went on that the bills
were the better team sunday night and i
think we're starting to come to the
conclusion
the bills may be the better team period
that the steelers
were living on borrowed time for too
long it finally caught up with them last
monday against washington
it continued last night against buffalo
and it gets no easier down the stretch
after a brief respite against the
bengals they've got the colts they've
got the browns and they really do have
to worry now
about potentially losing the division of
the browns
the bills by all appearances don't have
to worry about losing their division to
anyone they're on track for their first
division title in a very long time yeah
well i i mean first off can you hear me
yet are you still not hearing me i hear
you no good
i kind of liked it better one you know i
was getting used to not hearing you
i i did not have my life my my life was
a little brighter
good yeah good i got to enjoy two
minutes morning too
you're great great i know i was actually
panicked because i was like
what what the hell the hell is this
gonna work if he can't hear me
uh but i think you said a lot of the
right things because i've been able to
hear you throughout here
um you're right it's two teams trending
in two different directions too we've
kind of just seen
pittsburgh you know hit that plateau and
it's kind of fighting through that
moment in the year right now where
yeah we're not playing our best football
we've kind of hit a lull
you know and can we how do we get our
mojo back
and we saw buffalo go through that like
earlier in the year but buffalo
on the other hand like you're saying
mike i mean they're trending upwards to
where i think every week we look at them
we go
no this is this is a real deal team this
is no longer just
hey an afc fun to watch you football
team they showed again last night
they are capable of winning games
different ways and i think that's what
we're seeing here late
lately with buffalo hey josh allen you
know
he plays pretty smart football yeah it's
it's it's dangerous at times or whatever
but
he's capable of adjusting to a defensive
struggle type of game
you know their defense buffalo has
certainly got their feet underneath them
and all aspects of it and then playing a
one-dimensional pittsburgh team
certainly helped them
but they playing so much better on that
side of the ball there's a little
semblance of a running game i just think
you're seeing buffalo
yeah it doesn't always have to be josh
allen 350 yards air show they're showing
you they can do it a lot of different
ways which
you and i both know will translate to
success in the afc playoffs
and and look let's not forget what month
it is it's december this is the month
where the teams that are serious
about making a run at the championship
step up this isn't the time
to slide into a slump and lose multiple
games like the steelers have done this
is not an encouraging sign
you want to be winning you want to be
looking good you want to be on the verge
of dominance in december so you can
carry that into january when your season
is riding on every
single game and you know we saw the jinx
get put on
justin tucker last week by troy aikman
and joe buck
when they were going on and on about how
he never misses a kick inside of 40
yards and they went on and on and then
he missed the kick
last night our guys mike tarico and
chris collinsworth did it to ben because
they were talking about how he never
throws interceptions and no
interceptions and no
no no and then the pick six that was the
moment that was like the lightning bolt
yes that was like okay oh well
you know it looked like maybe the
steelers were gonna grind it out like
they
they have been able to grind out so many
wins this year
that was just the reminder that there is
a difference between these two teams and
and there's credit to
and this is there are patterns to every
nfl season and one very real pattern is
the stuff we see in september has little
relevance to the stuff we see in
december teams get better teams get
worse
teams almost never stay the same and
here we are
and you can pick out the teams you can
look at the standards you pick out the
teams that are stepping up in december
the bills to their credit are stepping
up they are reaching a new level they're
playing these prime time games
they are taking out 25 years of
frustration on anyone who is opposing
them
so they cannot just get to the playoffs
and lose like they did last year and
they did two years before that remember
they barely lost
they barely lost to the jaguars 2017
with tyrod taylor they had the
16-nothing lead
over houston and lost that game no they
want to show up in the postseason and
they want to kick
butt and and the evidence of that is
they're kicking butt now yeah i
i think you're exactly right and mike i
mean i simply that's that's the way to
put it
i i feel like they lost those games to
the tennessee
titans and the kansas city chiefs and
they went wait
we're not where we thought we were quite
yet or were not quite in that class of
the afc that maybe we thought and ever
since then
it's been really damn good football i
mean they've only lost on the hail
murray as we mentioned a lot of times
last week
and they've beaten other good football
teams along the way so
within that yes they're showing they're
battle tested
you know resilient get better whatever
you want to say
and then they have a quarterback that's
elite like we saw last night even though
it doesn't have to be amazing all game
he still made a few plays and throws
that i'm sure the pittsburgh steelers
players are like whoa
i i can't get over that or him moving
out of the pocket and doing those type
of things so
it's a well-rounded football team that's
for sure and
i i think they're a major player i mean
as you saw uh putting your power
rankings last week
you know buffalo buffalo i think is an
official
top five team i don't expect them to
fall off from that here through the
month of december
and they're gonna they're gonna make
some waves and some noise in the afc
playoffs
well chris when we consider the fact
that
the steelers lost to the bills and the
saints lost to the eagles
it very well could be chiefs one bills
two by the time the dust settles
sometime tomorrow morning
on our power rankings for the week it's
going to be packers bill's
chiefs not in that order but i feel like
those are going to be the top three
teams
right in the nfl and the stefan diggs
trade
a true definition of a win-win because
the vikings are very happy to have
justin jefferson
a budding superstar but the bills are
very happy to have stefan diggs a guy
who
has become not quite icing on the cake
but maybe something like that for the
bills he continues to play
at a very high level continues to be a
reliable target
for josh allen one of the big reasons
why that completion percentage
is so much higher than it was the first
two years of his career
if you don't have weapons it's hard to
be an efficient and effective
quarterback
i mean look at that targeted 134 times
100 receptions 1167 yards
five touchdowns and uh having a great
great season
with the best quarterback he's ever
played with by far in his career well i
don't know
all due respect kirk cousins i don't
want to say by far just say the best
quarterback that he's ever played with
his career
and josh allen and that's one of the
reasons why the bills are getting it
done because you know the running game
yeah really isn't all that impressive
for buffalo this is what josh allen can
do that's what's making that offense go
yeah that's right it's all framed around
josh allen they're just going to run the
ball
just to keep you honest you know
make your linebackers have to respect it
a little so they can throw a play-action
pass behind those guys from time to time
but diggs is phenomenal mike
and i think the beauty of him within the
fit of that offense and josh allen is
really like stefan diggs is one of those
guys where there is no weakness to his
game he really
is a well-rounded football receiver you
know i know we've talked about this in
the past but
he you know we see everything every game
he can do the
over the middle julian edelman wes
welker stuff in the new england type
offense because that's what they're
running there in buffalo
but he's also a game changer in the fact
that
you can line them outside and light them
up outside or just say
go turn on the after burners and run by
that guy and he will command double
teams at times and things like that
let alone he's got great feel for the
game so yeah he fits schematically
within their system
but then when you got a super freak like
josh allen who's going to run around and
make plays
i mean diggs all the time seems to be
the guy on the receiving end of those
he's got a great feel
for where allen wants to go the scramble
rules and all those type of things to
get yourself open so
it's like they're awesome at structural
schematical football and then they're
awesome at backyard football together
and uh that's a tough combination to
stop those two
what do you think changed from the first
half to the second half for the buffalo
offense was it just persistence
or was there something that you saw that
was different in what the bills were
doing well we we know the the the pick
six like you mentioned
turned the tides to the momentum of the
game a little bit but to me
this is and i i knew we're going to talk
about pittsburgh at some point
but this is my little fear of pittsburgh
you know mike i mentioned it last week a
little
like the in the initial emotions of the
football game kind of go away
and okay now it's late second quarter
third quarter
and yeah that's the time when guys start
to get a little tired
and that natural start intensity of the
game starts to wear off the offense
settles in
and we've seen this a few times from the
pittsburgh steelers throughout the year
where all of a sudden the pass rush
isn't quite as effective
we saw josh allen in the second half a
lot of times sitting back there
buying time moving when he had to but
not under duress
and then that steel or secondary is good
but it's not special it's just a solid
good secondary
you know it looks great at times because
it's had a great pass rush to help it
out but it's really not and i think
that's what we saw there and i think
it's the second week in a row
and i think it's a number of games this
year where we go man pittsburgh hasn't
been able to put this
team away well they found two teams this
last two weeks but it's a little
bit of that all year whether you go back
to you know carson wentz early in the
year and deshawn watson
and the denver bronco game same type of
thing but
uh i do think that was what like jumped
out to me mike about
the difference between the first half
and the second half with the buffalo
bills offense versus that steelers
defense
both teams do not have the balance that
you need to be effective in january when
it comes to run versus pass we talked
about the bills
let's look at the steelers james connor
came back last night we thought it would
give their running game a boost it did
not 10 carries for 18 yards
for conor they had 17 rush attempts in
all for 47 yards
37 pass attempts and only 187
yards that's barely five yards per
attempt right is just not good in
today's nfl there may have been a time
in the early 70s where that was
acceptable
it's not anymore and so they have not
even begun to solve their problems and
and look this game was close long enough
that they had a chance to establish the
running game
and they just can't and then whether
it's ben roethlisberger changing the
play at the line of scrimmage or
the offensive coordinator randy fickner
realizing i just have to go
in the direction of throwing the ball
because it's not that it's working
right but the run game clearly isn't so
we got to go with something that may
work a little bit
that they just can't get out of this
funk and
it it had kind of a snowball effect last
night
the various flaws of the steelers on
both sides of the ball just
gradually revealed themselves until you
woke up at one point and said
there's no way they're going to win this
game no i agree you know and
you're right like buffalo is no special
running team either but they got to 100
yards total right as an offense
and mike something that you brought up a
few years ago that i think you're
totally right
the other thing we can't forget about
with buffalo is when they get in the
playoffs they have that josh allen run
angle right where they can run the
quarterback and that's going to help
their run game out
they're they're hiding that right now
pittsburgh
i have no i don't have any hope for it
like
they're not the run game's not going to
get better you know dropping back
you know 700 times to throw the football
and then just
getting off the line of scrimmage to run
block uh
a hundred times all year basically you
know and i'm i'm just trying to make a
point here that it's so pass heavy
i i don't you i don't expect them to be
able to make some turn around into a
good running football team
you know you see here you know the
passing or the rushing yards last four
games that's that's not going to get it
done
or if it isn't if if you are going to
play this way mike like we talked about
last week
then you can't drop passes during the
early in the game and you can't throw
interceptions at a quarterback
and you have to play that four and five
yard
drop back pass game almost to a perfect
level and that's
a lot to ask and we're seeing you know a
few mistakes the last two weeks end up
losses
for the steelers hall of fame running
back jerome bettis had some interesting
comments last week to ed bouchette of
theathletic.com
about com the importance of commitment
to the run game right it's not something
that you can just decide to do
in december it has its roots in
training camp and the the the the the
physical dude the aggressiveness the
mindset
you can't just go say well we're going
to commit to the run game
halfway through the season no you either
commit to the run game
as part of the fabric of the foundation
of your team or you don't and for the
2020 steelers
the commitment to the run game was not
made and it's too late to rediscover it
now the problem
as the graphic points out the pass game
has not been great the last
four weeks ben rothersburg is averaging
under six yards per attempt
the last four weeks here's mike tomlin
coach the steelers who's had
many an interesting sound bite this year
talking about the team's offense after
last night's loss
mike is there anything that you can
think of that can get this offense
moving down field are you purposely not
working downfield everything seems to be
so short
everything's about the short game you
know we just got we got to win more
possession downs and thus possess the
ball more and give us more opportunities
the more snaps you get the more
opportunities you get to make some of
the dynamic plays
that you suggest it starts first with
staying on schedule and possessing the
ball
and we're not doing enough of that right
now so that makes some of the other
discussions
you know uh more troublesome now that
you have a full week before the next
game is that enough time to fix what's
going wrong on the offense
yes
succinct concise yes to the point it
will get
look they played three games in 12 days
yeah and we established last week that
plenty of teams played three games in 12
days at some stretch in the season
but this is a team that i think is a
little worn out a little beat up they
chose to travel day of the game the nfl
and the nflpa allowed them to do so just
so they could
kind of be home one more night so this
is a team that i think very much
benefits from the full week to prepare
and the fact
that the next team up is the cincinnati
bengals that is a way to get back
on track and feel good about yourself
going into those last two games which
will not be easy
but they do have to figure it out
but what can you do at this stage of the
season with three games left to
fundamentally change the nature of your
offense
we're at the point where it is what it's
going to be
and what it's been isn't great no i i
mean
you're right mike and you know like to
to the to the point with like the 12-day
thing
you're right right all teams got to go
through it but i will say pittsburgh had
to go through it in a different way
you know most teams you get to wrap your
head around it for weeks and weeks at a
time
pittsburgh it was wait are we playing
are we not playing are we playing wait
now our next game's that day
holy cow we got to play then now and
then we have a sunday night game against
josh allen on the buffalo bills
that's a whirlwind i think that's a
little more emotional and tougher on a
football player than the normal three
games in 12 day
aspect right i mean at least to me but
you know mike to what you're saying i
think you're spot on
they've become predictable
within their predictableness does that
make sense probably not but maybe it's a
negative
simpsonism but we know so i'm still
stuck
i'm still stuck on the fact that you
dusted off whirlwind hey
hey watch out this might really put you
in a whirlwind watch out here okay
but but they they we know they're
predictable within throwing the football
and being in the shotgun
and now they've become even pricked we
know you're gonna throw the ball in the
shotgun
now we know you're just gonna throw the
ball five and six yards at a time
and it's these little areas we got to
defend and it's become even
more predictable you know that's the
point of what i'm saying and you're
right mike like
they're not going to change they're not
all of a sudden getting an attitude on
the offensive line we saw last week they
got down to the one foot line against
the washington football team and all of
a sudden they tried to become a running
team
and they couldn't get an inch to get in
the end zone it's not going to change
jerome bettis is exactly right
now what can change is how you're
throwing the football
you can change that you can start to do
hey mike they got all these receivers
some of the speed sweep
motion stuff hey let's keep a tight end
in
and let big ben sit in the pocket and
we'll have an extra guy or two block and
now we can send juju
and chase claypool and deontay johnson
down the field with more aggressive
passing
uh patterns and schemes that way that to
me is something that
yeah the run games lost but we can add
that onto the offense and we haven't
seen
that next step you know it's just like
they were like hey the four and five
yard passing game's working
let's just keep doing it let's keep
doing it let's keep doing it well now
it's not working everybody's all over it
and you got to start throwing something
out of these defense are you going to be
in big trouble pittsburgh
yeah if they know what you're going to
do it makes it so much harder to do what
it is that you're already struggling to
do and
a couple of weird little things with the
steelers before we move on to the next
game
juju smith shoes to we saw the video
last night during the game of him
doing a pre-game dance routine on the
buffalo bills logo well that's cute and
that's fun and juju is a good guy
but it pissed off the bills sorry london
and why
that's gratuitous it's it's it's an
unforced
error that gets the other team riled up
when you don't need to give a good team
any more reason
to want to come kick your butt so why do
it what's the benefit of doing this
pre-game
dance routine on the other team's logo
does it every day
right i know i know but what's the point
maybe somebody needs to say to him hey
juju you're pissing the other team off
it may not be the best thing for you to
do
maybe find someplace else to do your
pregame dance routine if it's becoming
detrimental to the cause
maybe it's something that we shouldn't
do and then lastly back to the beginning
of this segment when i couldn't hear you
and i also
couldn't hear what was being piped
through right i did see though
the eric ebron approaching josh allen
while he's doing the interview with that
strange passive aggressive hey great
game bro
i i t that that's just weird and i think
weird is the best way to describe the
steelers right now
they are just a weird team and i don't
mean that in a pejorative way i mean
that in a
i don't get it way what is going on here
way
what are you going to do to position
yourself to win
in january way am i raw well i
i think maybe for me you're overblowing
it a little bit
i mean juju has been doing it all year
so i i don't know what to say i mean we
didn't hear about it when they went 11-0
you know what i mean i'm sure it's
pissed a lot of teams off you're right
i'm not saying it's right or wrong
that's just what he does he's johnny
social media he's johnny tick-tock
it's how my kids know him and all that
doesn't make it right you're right
but that's just the world we're in right
now um you know
the what was the other aspect of that
you were talking about oh the arrogant
it did the ebron thing was just weird it
is it was weird i'm with you there but i
think
it's do they know each other from
somewhere it sounded like it was like
uh you know like hey i know you i'm just
going to say hi real quick i know you're
on tv let me get the hell out of here
but hey one thing i can count on with
the pittsburgh steelers
is that guy that we watch clips of every
week
even though it wasn't good and they
ain't been good lately mike tomlin is
gonna be on their butt this week
and they will they have a driving force
of a guy that
you know can take some of the weirdness
away like you're saying and get
everybody back on page and be like what
the hell are we doing
and he'll get a few guys on the defense
riled up and get them to be leaders in
the locker room
and get everybody like you know standing
tall and
and on their p's and cues again and i i
have faith in this dealers i'm not
counting them out yet
i'm not i i think they can make some of
those adjustments on the offensive side
of the ball
defense is still damn good but they're
going through a little rut right now and
they got to figure a way to get out of
it
well that week 17 game against the
browns could ultimately be for all the
marbles in the afc north and it's
amazing to think that's even a
possibility
when the steelers were running away with
the division and of all the teams in the
division
to have a chance to catch them the
browns are not the team
that we thought it was going to be we
thought it was going to be the raven
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports